Exclusive new
reporting on a
previously unreported episode in the Mar
a Lago documents case.
It comes as attorneys for the former
president
met today
with Justice Department
officials and signs increasingly indicate
that special counsel Jackson's
probe could be in its final stages.
Seen as Kaitlan
Collins is here with more.
So walk us through this exclusive
reporting about Mar a Lago. Okay.
It's a bit of a bizarre story,
so bear with me.
But it was in last October.
We are told that this maintenance worker
at Mar a Lago drained the pool.
And when they drained the pool,
it caused a flood that flooded this room
that we are told
has the computer servers
which store the surveillance footage
on them.
That's important
because we know prosecutors
have been looking
at the surveillance footage from Mar
a Lago.
They've subpoenaed it several times.
They've requested that
they preserve records several times.
What we don't know is whether or not
this was an intentional flooding
or if it was genuinely,
genuinely a mistake.
But the maintenance worker
who was the one
who drained the pool in October,
which is the busy season at Mar a Lago,
also I should note,
is someone
who is caught
the eye of the prosecutors here.
They've seized his phone.
They've talked to him.
He's someone who was seen
on surveillance footage
that they have moving boxes at Mar
a Lago.
We don't know exactly which boxes,
but he was moving boxes
with another Trump aide.
But when it comes to
whether or not
the role that he played here,
they have a lot of questions about this
because we are told
that someone has testified
to these prosecutors
that nothing was damaged
when this flood happened in this room
where these servers restored,
that kept the surveillance footage.
But they view it as suspicious
and they've been asking witnesses
about it and raising questions about it.
And, of course,
they're investigating whether or not
there was any obstruction
and their investigation.
So I think it's just an odd instance
that raises a lot of questions. Will?
Yeah, it certainly has.
All the video been given handed over
that was on the servers. Do we know?
We're told
that we certainly know a lot of
it has been given over,
but they have been raising questions
about what we're told.
We learned so much of this, of
what investigators are asking people.
They've interviewed
basically everyone, I'm told,
but they have asked
what gaps in surveillance footage.
We know that they've had questions
for the security guys who were running
and in charge
of the surveillance footage.
So there have been questions
among that nature
of what exactly was turned over.
Trump Trump attorneys have said
that everything has been turned over.
This was technically up to the Trump
Organization that got these subpoenas.
But I still think it raises
a lot of questions just given, of course,
what we've seen play out.
What do we know about the meeting
between Trump lawyers
and the Justice Department today? Yeah.
So that was today.
So Trump attorneys
going into the Justice Department,
I'm told Jack Smith,
the special counsel
who is investigating
the classified documents
and January six was in that meeting.
They requested a meeting
from the Trump side
with Attorney General Merrick Garland.
They wrote him a letter.
They allege
that there was some
prosecutorial misconduct here.
They didn't really say what it was
pretty broad strokes
we know obviously,
though, typically
before someone is indicted,
their attorneys would like
to meet with them.
That's not what we're told
was the content of this meeting today.
I think it was raising questions
about the special counsel's
investigation.
They've certainly had some
some broad complaints.
Nothing really specific
about how this has been handled.
But they were inside
the Justice Department
for about 90 minutes today.
I think what's most telling is
what Trump was saying after
because he was posting,
why should he be charged
with no other presidents
have been charged.
We don't know that they
they told him
he was going to be charged for anything,
but he was certainly referencing.
I know you're
going to be anchoring at nine.
You got the former U.N.
Ambassador John Bolton
on the program, worked also obviously
in the Trump administration.
We'll watch for that right now
to get a better sense
of what goes on in these meetings
that attorneys
have with prosecutors,
as well as what goes into
the ultimate decision on indictments.
We're joined
by CNN senior
law enforcement analyst and former
FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe.
So what likely happens in a meeting
like this between Trump's attorneys and
DOJ officials?
Sure.
So, Anderson, it's
good to also know that
avoiding getting your client indicted
is every defense attorney's
first and biggest goal.
And so the last ditch effort
to try to avoid an indictment
is usually a meeting along these lines.
The defense attorneys request to come in
and basically explain to DOJ
why an indictment would be a bad idea.
It's a bit of a Hail Mary pass
like you would see
at the end of a football game,
one last ditch effort to avoid disaster.
What happens is the attorneys come in
and they say,
you know,
they'll make an argument
that the case is weak, that it shouldn't
go forward.
They have compelling
evidence of innocence.
And then they'll usually argue
some level of
it would be unfair to go forward
against against their client
if justice were to do so.
You typically don't hear
anything said
on the other side of the table.
DOJ will usually listen
to the presentation.
Give the attorneys all the time
they all the time they've requested
and at the end of the presentation say,
thank you very much for coming.
We'll give you a call
if we have anything to tell you.
It's a it's a long shot strategy.
It's worth the effort
if you're a defense attorney,
but it's certainly not worth
pinning your hopes on.
So when we hear that
the former president's attorneys
are claiming prosecutorial misconduct,
it may not be that
they have some smoking gun.
They have some heretofore
unheard of evidence.
This may just be a last ditch effort to
do whatever they can.
Yeah, I think it's highly
unlikely that they have
significant evidence of misconduct simply
because so many elements
of this investigation
have been ferociously
litigated between the two sides.
So you've had a lot
of judicial intervention
and oversight already
in this investigation.
We had, of course,
a search warrant that that took place.
Justice went back in front of
the judge and requested sanctions
against the Trump attorneys.
They've gone in and
and pursued an effort to pierce
the attorney client privilege
to get evidence from Trump's attorney
Evan Corcoran.
So there's been a lot
of judicial intervention would seem that
if there was actual misconduct,
that would have come out.
But my suspicion here, Anderson,
is that Trump's attorneys
know the only way
to get an attorney general
to really weigh in
and remove
or stop a special counsel has to be on
finding of misconduct
under the special counsel regulations.
That's really the only way
you can turn off
an attorney general
can turn off the special counsel effort.
So if they claim that
the special counsel engage in misconduct,
they can essentially fire him,
but they have to report that to Congress.
So that is a big ask.
That's literally swinging for the fences.
And based on your experience and what you
what you see publicly
do you believe Jack Smith is near the end
of his investigation?
I do.
I do. I think it can come very quickly.
These meetings
with defense attorneys
trying to basically plead their case
before it's indicted
usually come at the very,
very end,
right before the prosecutor
goes before the grand jury
and asks them to indict the case.
So I think we can see that happen
really any time now
and certainly within the next few weeks.
We've also seen
all the major witnesses
that we're aware of.
Most of them
anyway, we know
have already been
in front of the grand jury
We already understand there's
there's a lot of evidence
they have to work with here
just from
the things
that have been publicly reported.
They like we have much more than that.
So I think it's reasonable to expect
that this thing is
in its in its final stages
on the investigative side.
Well,
what do you make of the Kaitlan Collins
reporting about the Mar
a Lago pool flood
raising suspicions among prosecutors
Yeah, that's a really weird one.
I mean, it certainly indicates
gives you
an indication
of the high degree of suspicion that
each side has of the other.
And certainly DOJ
is investigating obstruction here.
We know that from the search
warrant application.
So they're going
to look at every possible act
as a possible,
you know, every every act
as a possible element of obstruction
in this case.
With with the witnesses already
saying that the flood didn't
really damage
the computers
it's hard to say
until we hear that
the Trump team is actually claiming
that they cannot produce
the videos requested under the search,
under the subpoenas
because the material was damaged
by water.
It's hard to say
that they're actually using that
as some sort of a.
What does obstruction look like? I mean,
from a legal standpoint.
So obstruction,
you know,
in order to charge
someone with obstruction,
you have to be able to prove
that they intended
to obstruct an official proceeding.
Right.
So an accident,
the accidental flooding of a room
with computers in it
without more evidence of actual intent
to stop or obstruct the proceeding.
In this case, the investigation wouldn't
probably rise to the level
of a chargeable offense.
However, conversations with your lawyer
in which you're lying to your lawyer
about where the docks are
and what's available to be searched,
as is also
allegedly taking place in this case,
that could very well be
end up as a chargeable offense.
All right.
Andrew McCabe, appreciate it. Thank you.